je m'appelle team j'ai eu les meilleurs
parents du monde c'est le jour des
enfants travail nous étions heureux tous
les trois les templeton notre vie était
parfaite
jusqu'au jour où tout a changé regarde
bien faire connaissance avec ton nouveau
[Musique]
il est en train de s'emparer de toute la
musique
regardez là il porte un costume on
dirait un petit homme il trop sport une
valise ya personne qui trouve ça au jeu
c'est pas un peu bizarroïdes
toi tu as bien trimballer ton à nyon en
peluche jusqu'à lâche rien à voir là
dedans crois moi un jour toi aussi tu
l'aimeras de tout mon coeur jamais
[Musique]
la procédure habituelle manque de
sommeil grève de la faim ils sont très
désorientée mais je crois que le garçon
se douter quelque chose pour m'occuper
du pays hôte et tu sais parler gougoux
gaga non si c'est vraiment parler tant
pis je sais par les toits montre moi tu
sais écouter femmes cherchent un double
espresso et voici tu ne trouverait pas
des sushis descendre quoi je tuerai pour
un rouleau temps et pis c'est en ce
moment que tu peux guère de la monnaie
[Musique]
qui disons simplement que je suis gosse
a tant que maman et papa apprennent tout
sa sieste flash qu'est ce que tu disais
[Musique]
je